au karabagh la trêve humanitaire n'est
toujours pas respectée les appels à la
paix se multiplient et la turquie
propose de négociation à quatre avec la
russie et les combats dépasse la ligne
de front les zones urbaines sont
touchées obligeant les civils à se
déplacer le point sur la situation avec
et notre correspondant à moscou
antoine coeur lors de sa dernière
rencontre avec son homologue arménien
sergueï lavrov avait mise en avant la
pertinence du format du groupe de minsk
c'est à dire avec la participation de
représentants de la france de la russie
et des états unis afin de trouver une
solution pacifique au conflit dans le
haut-karabagh aussi quand on lui a posé
la question sur le rôle que pourrait
être celui de la turquie dans la
résolution de ce conflit
voici ce qu'a été sa réponse nous ne
partageons pas la position formulée par
la turquie est exprimé à plusieurs
reprises par le président ali veut dire
ce que le colosse au président les ifrs
kosovo il n'y a aucun secret on ne peut
pas être en accord avec des déclarations
selon lesquelles une solution militaire
au conflit existe et qu'elle est
acceptable de lutte que je les nie tout
le ce malheureusement la turquie est
d'accord avec cela et réaffirmé qu'elle
soutiendrait toutes les mesures prises
par l'azerbaïdjan
afin de résoudre ce conflit y compris
des actions militaires
le ch ecoflex nous sommes en contact
avec nos collections depuis le début de
la crise j'ai parlé à notre reprise avec
le ministre turc des affaires étrangères
loto chevaux chameaux nous réaffirmons
néanmoins notre point de vue selon
lequel un règlement pacifique n'est pas
uniquement possible mais constitue le
seul moyen de parvenir à une solution
durable à ce problème quelques problèmes
puisque dans tous les autres cas le
conflit persistera même si un peu larvée
et sans accord politique durable
un jour les solutions militaires
échoueront et les hostilités se
poursuivront
szczesny cantons et des stigmates aubry
le royaume nomme peachum d'acajou soit
une sauce payet sur new skies en disant
ça le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères se place clairement sur la
même ligne que l'arménie il sert l art
of par la suite n'a pas manqué de
souligner le soutien de la turquie qui
peut se révéler parfois stratégique sur
d'autres dossiers
nous n'avons jamais qualifié la turquie
comme notre allié stratégique
nous avons des relations de partenariat
très étroite et dans de nombreux
domaines
ce partenariat possède un caractère
stratégique la turquie est en effet un
allié important de la russie dans bien
des domaines que ce soit sur le plan
politique ou encore économiques et
concernant les hostilités dans le
haut-karabagh sergueï lavrov a fait
savoir que les deux pays
avec deux visions bien différentes du
règlement de ce conflit